>>You have a visitor today.
Awesome.
>>Narrator: Any class, especially
one dedicated to history and culture,
can benefit from an encounter
with a visiting expert.
>>My name's Saaduuts.
I come from the Haida Tribe.
I come from the Edenshaw family.
>>Narrator: For many of these
students at Seattle's AS-1 school,
interacting with this Native
American would teach them more
than just a lesson in history.
>>Saaduuts: The chiefs were
allowed masks-- to wear masks.
Other people cannot wear masks
because they want to or you have
to have permission, and it's
not like Halloween or anything.
We put the mask on so we
could see what's in the wood.
>>Narrator: A master carver
from the Alaskan village
of Hydaburg, Saaduuts had a vision.
>>So, when we finish this, it
should be able to last 100 years.
>>He would transform a six-ton cedar
log into a traditional voyaging canoe
with help from the
seventh-graders from AS-1.
As part of their history
and culture class,
the students would spend two
school-day mornings each month
and volunteer on weekends to work
on the canoe at Seattle Center
for Wooden Boats in a project that
would eventually span three years.
>>The biggest challenge was
for the children to learn
about creating something from a
dream or a vision into reality
and taking time to
live through a process.
>>I'm going to have you start
here, and this is in here.
>>That if you don't give up and
you keep on working every day
in a disciplined fashion
and together as community
that you can complete
something absolutely wonderful.
>>I never doubted the kids.
The teaching's about
having confidence,
not about ever doubting them.
And I let them use all the tools,
heavy, the sledgehammers, wedges,
so that they could
meet the challenges.
>>It's really exciting to
be able to say yes to kids.
Yes, you can go out in the boat.
Yes, you can steer the boat.
Yes, you can hold this sharp
tool and cut wood with it
on a canoe or on a pond boat.
I've seen the kids come down
from Alternative School 1.
Sometimes they might be a bit
tentative in the early part
of the morning, but then
they start getting into it
and they start becoming really
engaged with each other,
and they collaborate and they laugh.
And when they get something
accomplished,
there's just a great
shine in their smile.
>>And then when you make your stroke,
you'll come back and
rest it on your lap.
>>Former AS-1 Principal Ron Snyder
helped launch the canoe project.
>>It's important as warriors to look
good, because that's who you are
when you paddle that canoe.
The canoe us a historical vehicle,
and it often went on adventures,
and you will present yourself
as warriors, as a proud people.
>>An advocate of expeditionary
learning, Snyder believes
that there's no substitute
for hands-on lessons.
>>Experience-based education sticks.
You really find out not about
some twisted figment of history
but about you, yourself and your
relationship to your history.
>>Saaduut: [singing]
>>They chose to tap their paddles
in synchronized sound motion
to what Saaduuts was singing on
the dock as the Haida paddle song.
>>Saaduut: [singing]
>>That came from their
heart, from their rhythm.
They really got it, how sharp they
looked, how powerful they were,
and there was a tremendous
aura of pride in the canoe.
>>Tell me what it felt
like to paddle.
>>It was really moving, because you
were all paddling at the same time
and then when you're coming back, we
would paddle and then hit our paddles
against the side when we rested.
And there was this rhythm to it and
it sounded almost like music, and--
>>As the canoe neared
completion, teachers,
parents and students
prepared for a trip to Alaska
to present their canoe
to the Haida Tribe.
>>So, you're all going to be able to
paddle it, we hope, but you can't do
that unless you pass the float
test and the capsize test.
>>All: [singing]
>>In April of 2004 the AS-1
group traveled to the village
of Hydaburg in southeastern Alaska.
In culmination of their
three-year effort,
they paddled their canoe
ashore and presented it
as a gift to the community.
>>It made my heart cry with
joy to see the connection,
the cultural connection
when my people are standing
on the beach waiting
to receive the canoe.
It touched everybody on both
sides of the connection,
and that's what the
whole thing is about.
>>I just loved the idea that the kids
could study Northwest Native canoe
culture and the importance of the
canoe, not just from textbooks,
not just from lectures
but actually meet people,
get into the culture,
produce a canoe.
So that's really an
integrated form of learning.
>>And if everybody lift together
and help, it's going to work good.
No rushing.
If there's anything-- everybody
set it down together, all right?
One, two, three.
Hoo. Hoo.
>>In 2005 the AS-1 community carved
a second canoe and donated it
to another Alaskan village,
and Seattle's cultural
carving connection continues
with two more canoes
now under construction.
>>It was just so great to
be part of this spirit,
where everybody was coming
together, creating this thing.
We just don't get much of an
opportunity to do things like that
in the world today, and so it
was-- it went beyond the school.
It stretched out into
the bigger community,
so it was a really,
really special thing.
>>Through the eyes of the child,
change will come if we teach him,
if we take the time to teach him.
They're hungry for this new way.
It's a new but old way.
>>All: [cheers]
>>We can't keep them on the
side and expect them to learn.
They have to have hands on, be part
of it, and too much of the things
that are going on now is
we're cutting too many things
out of the children's life:
working with their hands
and their mind and their spirit.
>>All: [singing]
>>We could tell the story,
but if they practice the story
and do a hands-on, it's a living
story, and that's why they want
to be here and be part of it.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org